[music]
So, you have two marks from Boston
Dynamics uh on the stage, although I'm
no longer with the company.
>> Neither am I.
>> True.
>> And it's funny when when people stop me
in the crowd and ask to take a selfie
with me. I know they're confusing me
with you.
>> Um
>> but you're not wearing the right shirt.
>> No, that's true. Yeah. So
I would love to start at the very
beginning. Take us back to the first hop
when in the early 1990s the first robot
started hopping.
So when I was a graduate student at MIT,
I uh went to my first conference in my
life and there was a man uh Bob McGee
showing a six-legged robot uh that he'd
built. And in those days, there weren't
too many legged robots at all. And this
conference was all biologists. Uh it was
about animal locomotion.
And I looked at his robot and then first
I thought, "Wow, that is really cool
six-legged robot." But then I looked at
it and thought, "This is all wrong. This
is static. It's going slowly because it
doesn't want to uh fall over."
And I thought about animals. I'd been
studying biology a little bit. And you
know, we fly through the air when we
walk, when we run. uh we balance, we
store energy in our tendons and muscles.
And I just thought, okay, there's got to
be another way. And that launched me on
the idea of making a pogo stick robot
where the energetic cycle of kinetic
energy of flying, potential energy of
elevation, potential energy of
compression were key ingredients. But
and on top of that, balance. And for the
next many years that drove what I worked
on.
>> And do you remember the year when you
had the first pogo stick robot which is
now in the Boston Dynamics Museum I
believe? Right.
>> You know in 1981 and 83. In ' 81 we had
a simplified uh pogo stick robot. In 83
we had one that operated freely in the
room. I say operated freely, but it had
wires that went to a computer in the
next room because there were no
microprocessors. It had hydraulic hoses
that went to a big 200lb pump. Uh but we
made it as free as it could be and it
was balancing itself uh walking around.
>> Do you still remember who was in the
room then? And are you still in contact
with everybody that was in the room?
Jeff Coaching was there, Jessica Hajins
was there, Mike Japonis, Jean Hastings,
>> that was the and Ben Brown.
>> Amazing.
>> Um, so the leap of faith question in the
early 1980s, most roboticists believe
that dynamic balance was too hard. Um,
and that stable robotics was the only
path. What made you believe that it was
going to be possible?
you know when I I give a culture talk at
uh where when I speak and I talk one of
the ingredients is uh technical
fearlessness. Now I don't think at the
time I knew I had technical fearlessness
and looking back you could just call it
stupidity or overconfidence.
I didn't know how we were going to make
a thing do that, but I thought that that
was the important thing to do. And so we
just flung oursel at it. And uh
amazingly, it didn't turn out to be as
hard as I thought it would be. Almost
disappointingly
when we had the first one-legged freely
moving hopping machine working in the
lab, it was a little boring.
Uh, and it wasn't until when I made
presentations, if I showed outtakes
where you could see how quickly it could
fall over, if it didn't work right, uh,
that's when people said, "Oh, that's
really cool."
>> Was that the beginning of the viral
videos, or was it really when Big Dog
was falling on the ice and being kicked
that you knew you were on to something?
The beginning of the outtake videos
was when I was still a graduate student,
Dan Whitney. Dan Whitney was a robotics
researcher who worked at the Draper lab
at uh which was connected to MIT at the
time. And he was doing assembly,
automatic assembly of uh water pumps
from a car. And he had this great videos
where the the arm would pick up a
electric screwdriver, screw something
down, and then at the end, if he didn't
do it right, boom, all the parts went
flying in the air, uh, because he had it
on a spring-loaded table, uh, that was
made so he didn't have to break the
table when it didn't work right. And I
looked at that and thought that was
fantastic. And so, ever since I used
outtakes, and outtakes really inspire an
audience. Yeah,
>> I had people visit my lab at MIT once
where I showed them around. We we showed
them technical stuff for 30 minutes and
then I showed them outtakes and one of
them said, "Oh, I heard you give a talk
15 years ago and they hadn't realized it
was me. Uh, but the outtakes, you know,
stuck in their head."
>> Yeah. And YouTube really of course
accelerated that. Yeah.
>> Yeah. YouTube made it possible to get
communicate with a lot of people and
just show whatever you wanted to show.
>> So entertainment was always a part of
Boston Dynamics and especially you
always you told me this funny story
about the the movie with Shan Connory
where they looked at the robot and said
yes we need a robot in the Shan Conory
movie and the disaster that uh occurred
then
>> you want to hear about that?
>> Yeah.
So before Boston Dynamics existed, when
it was still the MIT lab, uh the the
director uh a very famous director,
Philip Calfman, who had done the
unbearable lightness of being, which was
a famous movie, uh his people called me
up and said, "We need a robot for a
scene in this movie." And we'd never
been out of the lab, and I thought,
"Okay, maybe this will be a good time to
see what the real world is like." So, we
packed up uh two of our robots and four
graduate students and went out to 20th
Century Fox thing
and uh although the first day we got
some stuff working, it was a total
disaster. Uh we were out on this
location, they didn't understand our
world and we didn't understand theirs.
Fortunately, by the end of the week, we
got some footage which you can see in
the movie. So, we have a scene with Sean
Conry, Wesley Snipes, two of my robots,
and two of my grad students in the
background, and then there's a guy
playing me.
>> So, that was an eye-opening experience.
>> The real world is different than the
than the lab.
>> Yeah. You always said that you prefer
building over simulation. And in an era
where so much is going towards
simulation,
um, is that still your instinct? And in
an ML first world, how do you think
about this?
>> Today, I'm a convert.
But for many years,
uh the simulation tools, at least the
ones we had, were so slow, so hard to
work. You really needed expert people to
do everything. And we were really expert
at building a machine, getting it into
lab, instrumenting it so we could
collect data from it, and just running
it. And from day one, we had people to
repair the robots. So we didn't count on
them working without breaking, but we
counted every day cycle was come in, do
some work, break the robots. The repair
team would come in, repair the robots,
and then rinse and repeat. So it was
possible to do things physically, and
the the tasks we were doing were
simpler. But today, it's a changed
world. Physics-based simulation.
Now, it has to be physics-based
simulation developed by real engineers
who have real data and know what the
physical robot really is, not a not a
video game version of the robot. That's
a little bit of dig at Nvidia because in
the early days, their simulations were
really video game simulations. Now,
they've done a lot of work to make them
much more physically realistic. There's
still some closed parts that need to be
open. I guess I shouldn't do a tirade on
Nvidia, but um now using physics-based
simulation and reinforcement learning,
you can get so much more behavior
without uh the hardware being uh in the
loop the whole time.
>> Yeah.
>> So, of the 10,000 failures, was there
one that stood out where you had like a
breakthrough moment or an aha moment or
something that taught you more than
others?
Well, there was a
a success that looked like a failure
when we first when we took Big Dog out
and uh it was marching around our uh
parking lot. This was in Boston, so it
was the winter and there was a patch of
ice and the robot went on the ice and
started flailing but stayed on its feet
and that appeared in the first video we
ever put on uh YouTube and uh you know
it was a uh a big success in getting
people to pay attention. We were a
company with no investors.
Uh we didn't have a PR organization. In
fact, we never had a PR organization
until uh we were acquired by Google uh
many years 20 years in
uh yet everybody around the world uh who
was interested in this kind of thing
started to know who we were. So that was
one. But I would say more generally that
we learn much more
by seeing something that's not working
than when it is working. And it's a lot
more fun. Basically, if you can crash
the robot in some dramatic way, uh it uh
it's fun for everybody who works in the
lab. You know, sometimes we had a lot of
hydraulic robots. We'd break a hose and
there'd be a water fountain.
>> Uh
>> I don't know, we caught one on fire. I'm
not really supposed to talk about it,
but we had one uh you know, a gasoline
powered robot uh with a battery problem
that caught on fire, and uh that was
pretty spectacular.
So as a as a more commercial entity,
there's always a tension between very
cool product demo and commercially
viable product. How do you think about
that?
>> There have been times when other people
showed our outtakes in a way that was
very painful because it didn't situate
it in the context of what we had
achieved. Uh after the first DARPA
robotics challenge, it wasn't only our
outtakes. DARPA released a video that
was all outtakes of the humanoid robots.
And a lot of those robots had done very
good performance in the testing. And the
whole idea was to push them as far as
you could until they failed. Yet, their
outtake thing didn't really couple it
with the successes. So, you know, that's
a thing. I think people appreciate the
honesty of showing what's working and
what's not working. We try and do that.
Sometimes it's very hard to be, it's not
that we're dishonest, but you want to
show the thing that you think is the key
problem and you don't show every other
thing that's going on and sometimes you
get criticized for that. But
>> but at Boston Dynamics, the policy was
always to only show what the hardware
and software can currently do. How do
you feel that's going for the rest of
the industry?
>> Um,
let me let me switch that question to
the early days of Boston Dynamics. We
were operating in a desert.
Pretty much no one cared about this
stuff. Um, you did it because you loved
it. Absolutely only because you loved
it. you could get stuff funded, but the
idea that you were going to make a
product that was going to make money was
nowhere in sight
>> uh for many of those years. And we were
funded by uh you know, DARPA is always
looking to the future and trying to make
new things happen. And we were great at
exploring that future. The reason I left
DARPA uh Boston Dynamics and went to Ray
is because that's really what I want to
do is look a little further out, figure
out what the hardest problems are and
work on them. Um, and I think today
there's a lot of people who are overly
optimistic about where this is going to
go or how quickly it's going to go. Uh,
and it sure was in some ways nicer not
having so much uh, attention and uh,
potential competition, I guess. But it's
also very exciting to see. I mean, we
have all these friends and colleagues
now.
>> Yeah.
>> Who weren't really there. They were
mostly saying, "Oh, Rbert's crazy. Why
is he wasting his time doing that?
>> Yeah, we still think that you're crazy,
but you're not wasting your time. Do you
want to talk about uh the Ray Institute
for a couple of minutes and why you spun
out of Boston Dynamics and what Ray is
currently focused on?
Yeah, you know, as we as uh Boston
Dynamics was owned initially by Google
after 20 something years of being
independent
uh and then we went to SoftBank, there
became more and more interest in seeing
if we could uh commercialize and make
money and uh my uh second in command for
many of those years, Rob Plater wanted
to do commercialization. So I stepped
down as CEO as CEO became chairman and
made him the CEO. And over the years the
company became more and more commercial.
We spent more and more time, money and
talent on reliability, engineering, cost
reduction, marketing, customer success,
and less on breaking the glass of trying
something that wasn't going to mature uh
for uh years in the future.
Uh, even the dancing robot thing, I was
in charge of the dancing robot stuff
because I was the only one who could
make us do that. Everybody else was too
focused on practical things. And now, of
course, it's part of the Boston Dynamics
culture. Um, so anyway, so my idea for
Rey was a zero revenue
uh further look out to the to the longer
timeline of at least 5 years, seven
years and uh work on those problems
because I they're still today essential
real dexterity rivaling people doesn't
exist in robots and we're working on
that. mobility that could go out and
take the subway or the public
transportation in Paris doesn't exist in
robots and we're working on that through
our Zurich office. Uh
we have an ethics and policy group
trying to understand how workers are
going to feel about the robots and uh
what ways we can enable their commercial
success uh by understanding some of
those problems. Another thing, any of
you people could come into a factory and
in 10 or 15 minutes watch another person
do a job. And even if you couldn't do it
as an expert, you could get started
doing productive work.
Most robots take a team of very skilled
programmers, subject matter experts,
months of programming in order to get
them to work. So, we have a project
called watch, understand, do, which you
could call on the job training. And
we've been working on that for four
years, and it is really tough, but we're
going to keep working on it. And uh I
think we can make progress on that uh
eventually.
>> So, when my kids are my age, what will
robots do around us?
>> How old are your kids now? [laughter]
>> 20. So in 20 years
I you know they there'll there will be a
lot more robots doing a lot more things.
Uh I'm I'm confident in that. But that's
a 20-year horizon. I think I think it's
going to you know one of the things is
that the culture of factories and
warehouses and people's homes are not
yet ready uh for this new technology.
And so part of the job I mean you know
so everybody knows Mark was leading a
huge effort a a very successful effort
selling Boston Dynamics robots and one
of the things he did was make a customer
success team which helped develop the
culture smooth over the problems of
getting the robots into a money-m world
and that's still there. You know, I test
drove my first Tesla, the Roadster, and
it took 12 years before the S product
came out. And this is a car. Everybody
knows how to buy a car. Everybody knows
how to drive a car. Everybody wants a
car. And this robots aren't there. So, I
think we can expect 10 years for the
culture to develop uh to get the kind
the levels of uh acceptance that you
want. But lest anybody think I'm a
naysayer, I love robotics. I'm in it for
life. Uh I'm doing it because of the
love and I think it's so much fun seeing
what you can make them do. Uh seeing how
they can screw you up
and uh you know that's what it's about
for me.
>> Any specific applications that you're
particularly excited about? You know,
we're trying not to be an application
group, but to do the work that will
enable all applications. Dexterity is
one of those. Uh real mobility or
semantic uh navigation is one of those
things. If we could succeed with on the
job training, I think that would uh
really help and uh I think uh a lot of
the people here could benefit from that
uh progress.
>> When are we going to see robots in our
homes?
Uh I don't know. Uh the the people who
have tried haven't been too successful
yet. Uh even Alexa, you know.
>> Yeah,
>> I I mean I have a couple of Alexexas and
I use it, but uh it hasn't really gone
beyond that level.
>> But is Alexa a robot?
>> You know, I I'm a big tent robotics
person. So, uh sure. It's it's part it's
one of the ingredients. When are we
going to have legged robots in the home?
I mean, obviously people have vacuum
cleaners uh already and and Alexexas,
but when are we going to have legged
robots in the home? I think if you're
going to be at all practical, you have
to realize I think the warehouse is uh
already starting to be a success and
some companies is a success. The factory
is next. But the home has the three
problems of real functionality that's
useful, cost, and safety. And all those
three are fighting each other. So I
think it's still going to be a little
while. On the other hand, it's a huge
market potentially. So it'll motivate a
lot of people.
>> Yeah.
>> Great. Well, I know that the audience
would love to ask questions, but we
don't have that capability, so um they
will need to find you afterwards, but
Thank you so much for the talk. Really
appreciate it.
>> That's fine.
>> That's right. Yeah.